we are asked to graph the function f of
x is equal to negative three x squared
plus eight so we'll do this by
essentially trying out different points
for x and seeing what we get for f of x
and then graphing it but the first
question i have for you is just looking
at this function definition for f of x
what do you think
this type what type of graph will this
be will this be a line will this be a
parabola will this be something else a
circle something else maybe something
else bizarre or strange
well this is pretty clearly going to be
a parabola here you have a the function
is defined it's negative 3x squared so
you have this second degree term here
you don't have any x thirds or x to the
fourths or anything else bizarre so this
is going to be a parabola now the other
thing that we could think about is
whether the parabola is going to open up
like that or whether it's going to open
down like that and just looking at this
function definition do you have any
intuition of whether it's going to open
up or it's going to open down
well if you look at the coefficient on
the x squared term the negative 3
that tells you that this parabola is
going to open down it's going to open
down
so with that intuition now that we we
know it's going to be a parabola we know
it's going to open down let's actually
try to graph the thing
and let's
let me draw some axes here so let's say
that this is my
x-axis
so that's my x-axis
and then let's make this right over here
this is my y-axis
my y-axis and let me make a table of
values and see what f of x what values f
x takes on
so
on one column i'm going to do
my values for x and over on the right
i'm going to do my values for f of x and
then we can plot these things and
actually i want to take all of these
values before i draw the scale on these
axes so i know what what might be an
appropriate scale so i'm just going to
try a bunch of values so let's try first
what happens when x
is equal to negative 2.
so when x is equal to negative 2 and i'm
just picking numbers that will be
relatively easy to compute when x is
equal to negative 2 what's f of x well f
of x is going to be negative 3 this
negative 3
times negative 2 squared
times negative 2 squared
plus
8 which is going to be equal to let's
see negative 2 squared is 4 positive 4.
when we multiply that times a negative 3
which gives us negative 12 plus 8
gives us
negative 4.
let's try another point let's see what
happens when x is equal to negative 1.
what do we get for f of x then
well f of x is going to be negative
three times negative one squared
plus eight so that's going to be see
negative one squared is just one so
you're in and then that times negative 3
is negative 3 negative 3 plus 8
is 5.
now what does f of x equal when x is
equal to 0
well this is pretty easy to compute when
x is equal to 0 you get negative 3 times
0 squared
negative 3 times 0 squared which is
equal to and we could write that either
way
negative 3 times 0 squared
plus 8 well this just simplifies to 0
and so you're just left with eight
now let's see what happens when x is
equal to one what do we get for f of x
well it's going to be negative three
times one squared
plus eight
so one squared is just one negative
three plus eight is equal to five
and then finally what do we get
when x is equal to positive two what
does f of x equal or another way of
thinking about what is f of two
well
let's think about it you get negative
three times two squared plus eight
two squared is four times negative three
is negative twelve plus 8 is equal to
negative 4. so let's see if we can plot
this so the x values that i picked go
from negative 2 to positive 2. so let's
make this negative 2
negative 1. this is 0 this is positive 1
and then that could be positive 2.
and then our our f of x values or or we
could we're essentially graphing y is
equal to f of x so i can even say this
is going to be the graph of y is equal
to f of x or f of x values take on
things between
negative four and positive eight
so let me try to draw that so if this is
positive eight
that's positive eight
that is positive
four and this is negative four
this is negative four and if that's
positive four then this is positive six
and then that right there is five that
is seven this would be two that would be
three and then that would be one
now let's graph the points
when x is negative two f of x is
negative four and actually i could say
this is the y is equal to f of x axis
i'm going to plot f of x i'm graphing
and this is going to be the graph of y
is equal to this function
so let's let's graph negative 2 negative
4 so that gets us
when x is negative 2 f of x is negative
4. so it's right over there
when x is equal to negative 1
f of x is equal to 5.
f of x is equal to 5. and we're saying
that y is equal to f x in this in this
context
when x is 0 f of x or y
i could even write over here i could say
y
is equal to f of x when x is equal to 0
our f of x is 8.
x is 0 f of x is eight
when
x is one f of x is five when x is one
y equals f of x is five and then finally
when x is equal to two f of x is equal
to negative four
so 2
negative 4 gets us right there and now
we can connect the dots we know this is
going to be a parabola
and i will do it in blue
so my best attempt i like to draw it as
a dotted line just because it's easier
to not
mess up
so
it would look something like that and it
keeps on going just like that and then i
can actually make the line a little bit
a little bit more solid
so we see that we definitely got a
parabola and just as
just as our intuition told us our
ability to inspect the coefficient on
the x squared term told us that our
parabola is indeed
opening
is indeed opening downwards